one I believe in God I know some people
don't but many people who don't
nonetheless believe in something greater
than themselves I believe that that if
you believe in something greater than
yourself that that your life will be
more full and unproductive so I believe
in God and by the way in believing in
God I believe therefore we are all his
children and I believe that God loves
all of us and I believe he loves us as
you would love your children some were
doing naughty things some are doing nice
things but you love them all and and and
i believe that i will be measured and
you will be measured based upon what you
have done for your fellow children of
god and and that means your spouse your
children and your community more broadly
so that's a big part of what's important
to me which are the people around me
that I care for the person I care for
most in life is my wife we met in high
school I love her passionately she is
the most important person in my life if
I could do anything on any day it would
be to be with her that's what I enjoy
most in life clothes they're after is to
be with my kids my my boys and their
wives and now 23 grandkids the greatest
joy I have in life is being with them
sitting around in the backyard or at a
beach just being with my grandkids and
family is the greatest source of
happiness and the most important thing
to me coming beyond that is a circle
which includes my church my congregation
the people i know at church and my sense
of service to them service in the
broadest sense giving back in the sense
of caring for people around me is is
follows from that belief in something
bigger than myself i happen to believe
that the currency in life is the people
that you love and the care for you the
friends you have most of what you've
learned here you forget the people you
bet here you'll remember the rest of
your life and and will form a big part
of your of your wealth that's your
balance sheet when life is over who
loves you and you love and who are your
friends and and and how close are they
to you so what's the most important
thing to me my God my my wife my kids
and and my fellow human beings and and I
dissipate and engage with with with
people large through campaigns through
speeches through serving and charities
in all sorts of ways and and the rewards
the rewards that come back are our
rewards in people in friendship in love
and and that's what makes the most
impact in my life